Previously through the Lefkowitz case,
we discussed advertisements that
constituted contractual offers.
Today we're going to continue discussing
the advertisements this time by
examining and exceptionally entertaining
case Leonard Versus Pepsico,
which was decided by the southern district
of New York in 1999 hopefully after
having considered these two cases,
you'll think a bit differently or at least
more critically when you see an ad or
commercial.
In the 1990s Pepsico
conducted a promotion.
The company allowed
consumers of its products,
most notably Pepsi and Diet
Pepsi to a Mass Pepsi points.
By purchasing those products,
those consumers could then use the Pepsi
points to buy specified merchandise.
They could then fill out and submit an
order catalog listing available products
and the respect of points they were worth.
In furtherance of this promotion,
Pepsico aired the following
television commercial
[inaudible]
as you just saw certain items
appearing in the commercial.
We're priced via subtitles with
various Pepsi point values,
a t shirt at 75 points,
sunglasses at 175 points,
a leather jacket at 1,450 points and of
course the commercial culminates with a
Harrier jet landing.
At the teenagers high school.
The jet is shown with the
subtitle 7 million Pepsi points.
The Pepsi Co Order Catalog did
not include the Harrier jet.
Nevertheless,
the plaintiff attempted to redeem the
Harrier jet after submitting a check to
the defendant for an amount sufficient
to purchase 7 million Pepsi points.
The company's promotion also permitted
consumers to purchase points directly at
10 cents per point. After Pepsico
rejected the plaintiff's effort,
the plaintiff sued the plaintiff argued
that the advertisement displaying as it
did a Pepsi point number seemingly as
the price for the jet constituted a valid
offer that he accepted
by submitting his check.
The defendant counter
that the advertisement was
clearly a joke and did not
constitute an offer.
The southern district of New York agreed
with the defendant granting summary
Judgment to Pepsico.
Typically,
advertisements do not constitute offers.
Section 26 of the restatement second
of contracts which explains that a
manifestation of one's willingness to
enter a bargain does not itself constitute
an offer includes an official
comment that specifically addresses
advertisements.
That comment says,
business enterprises commonly secured
general publicity for the goods or
services they supply or purchase.
Advertisements are not ordinarily
intended or understood as offers to sell.
The same is true of catalogs,
price lists and circulars.
Even though the terms of suggested
bargains may be stated in some detail,
it is of course possible to make an
offer by an advertisement directed to the
general public,
but there must ordinarily be some language
of commitment or some invitation to
take action without further communication
as the restatements suggests,
and as we saw in Lefkowitz,
there are exceptions to the general
rule that advertisements are not offers.
Lefkowitz said that when
the advertisement is clear,
definite and explicit and leaves
nothing open for negotiation,
it constitutes and offer that creates
a binding contract upon acceptance.
But the restatement comment said that
even adds with term stated in some detail
may not constitute offers.
Might an ad need to clearly state that
is intended to serve as an offer in order
to be effective? Well, the answer is
under the restatement is possibly yes.
The comment also said that advertisements
are not ordinarily intended or
understood as offers to sell,
but under the objectivist
conception of contract formation,
we don't care what about whether the
offer or ordinarily intends or not.
For the communication to be an offer,
we care only about whether a reasonable
listener would interpret the ad as an
offer to sell.
Is it really true that a
reasonable listener would
ordinarily not understand an
ad to be an offer to sell?
Uh,
empowering the consumer to accept at
least say while reasonable supplies.
Last one problem with the
reasonable listener inquiry
is that it can be somewhat
indogenous. The law is looking at
what reasonable listeners think,
but reasonable listeners are simultaneous
simultaneously looking at what the law
things.
When a case like Lefkowitz or Leonard
says that ads are not to be trusted,
then reasonable listeners are less
likely to think that they are offers.
So from what you've
heard of the commercial,
what would constitute
acceptance by the plaintiff?
Intuitively we'd think payment of the
points would constitute acceptance.
But how would the plaintiff pay the
Po those points and to whom that the
commercial does not give us?
The answer is a primary reason why the
court held that the commercial did not
constitute an offer. In
the court's words, quote,
the commercial was not definite because
it reserve details of the offer to a
separate writing the catalog and did not
explain the steps necessary to accept
the offer.
The catalog of course which actually
constituted the companies offer did not
list the jet recall as well that the
advertisement said issue in Lefkowitz said
first come first serve.
The Pepsi Co commercial had no similar
limiting language as to quantity,
which meant that on the plaintiff's
theory the company would have to provide a
jet to every individual who amassed or
purchase the requisite Pepsi points.
The lack of such language also made the
commercial to indefinite to constitute
an offer because viewers of the commercial
probably wouldn't believe Pepsico
would risk the possibility that more
people would accept and the company had
Harrier jets to provide.
Here's a question to consider though.
Imagine the leather jacket depicted in
the commercial for 1,450 points was not
listed in the catalog,
but the plaintiff wanted it and attempted
similar similarly to redeem a Pepsi
points to get that merchandise
with the result have been the same.
It's similarly indefinite,
but the lack of limiting language is
certainly less of an issue for an article
of easily produced clothing.
The fact that supposedly offer wouldn't
seem objectively unreasonable or joking
and we'll talk about
joking in a few minutes,
would probably weigh heavily
in the court's analysis. Now,
Judge Cardozo might've reached a
different result in this case. Remember,
Justice Cardozo was the great
implied in Lucy Lady Duff Gordon,
and in the Allegheny college case,
would it really be so hard to imply,
uh,
a term that the offer was only good while
reasonable supplies last to avoid the
prospect of unlimited demand?
Implying additional terms could
resolve a lot of the indefiniteness,
uh, found in this commercial and this, um,
implying extra terms is already a standard
part of the law of offers which teach
us that offers can be accepted
by any reasonable means.
The plaintiff also argued and the court
rejected the theory that the commercial
represented the kind of reward offer that
we learned about in the carbolic smoke
ball case reward advertisements like
the one in carbolic are meant to induce
viewers to perform a specific action,
but the Pepsico advertisement did not
do this at most. The court found it.
It hurts viewers of Pepsico's commercial
to buy its products and accumulate
points and then look at the catalog
and figure out how to redeem them.
The Pepsico opinion also discuss joking
offers that we earlier discussed.
Uh,
with regard to Lucy versus Zimmer,
the Pepsico court indicated that an ad
or other communication is not an offer if
the party claiming an offer existed.
Uh,
if the party who claimed that an offer
existed had reason to know that the offer
was made in jest.
In other words,
whether something is an offer or a
joke is governed by an objective test,
would an objectively reasonable listener
believe the commercial constituted a
serious offer?
The court gave reasons why it found
the advertisement was clearly ingest.
These included that the teenager and the
commercial was a highly probable pilot.
That traveling to school in a jet is
an exaggerated adolescent fantasy.
And that given the Harrier jets military
uses depiction of such a jet of such a
jet as a way to get to school in
the morning is clearly not serious.
And finally,
and perhaps most compellingly amassing
the requisite Pepsi points by drinking
Pepsi would require drinking about
190 Pepsi's a day for 100 years.
So what have we learned?
First,
we reiterated the rules articulated
when advertisements constitute offers.
They're only going to be offered as if
the advertisement specifies a clear,
definite and explicit means of
acceptance and has explicit terms,
uh, and maybe indicates that
it intends to be an offer.
Let's and let's consider for
a moment the policies, uh,
arguments supporting this
rule of definiteness.
Why don't we want all that [inaudible]
ties mints to Constitute Offers?
Well,
advertisements,
especially commercials are viewed by a
huge number of people combined with the
period of time between the display of
the ad and a viewer is acceptance. Uh,
construing ads as offers would
inspire tons of litigation's,
which in turn might produce a chilling
effect on advertisements. Then again,
ads are trying to induce consumers to act.
It might not be so inefficient to put
the burden on the speaker to state when
ads, uh, with stated prices, uh,
are merely solicitations.
Second,
we revisited the joking offers question
and the idea of unilateral reward
contracts that we first studied in Zimmer
and the carbolic smoke balls case with
regard to joking offers,
we learned from Pepsico that
the acceptance of an offer
made in jest will not be
binding.
If an objectively reasonable listener
would not have believed that the person or
entity making the supposed offer was not
being serious because of Leonard Versus
Pepsico.
Federal judges are now in the business
of telling us why a commercial is funny.